what's the most pain you've ever felt
maybe the kind that leaves you more
machine and man
wait no stop Oh what is that
deal what why why are the visual effects
not done Deadpool 2 doesn't have a
subtitle it's just a to - but I mean you
were in charge of giving it a subtitle
what would you call it
Deadpool 2 it's all about cable it is
cable time how's that like a hammer time
I would call it - I love story
Bethesda think it is alone yeah I'm the
first one this is like a family sort of
love story like Deadpool - cheaper body
doesn't we were gonna call it Love
Machine but then it made no sense like
it just we could family matters not not
the bottom line is we decided that so
many movies had done that that it was
almost a cliche so we decided let's just
make a Deadpool - simple ironically
calling a Deadpool - felt the freshest -
yeah do it myself
cable and I'm from the future and I'm
always pissed off reach for the sky
cable is such a big part of this movie
it'd be part of this universe how do you
hope to see that character evolve now
well I mean now that we go into x-force
and we have Drew Goddard coming in I
think he's gonna create something really
special I think at the end of this movie
you start to get into the cable Deadpool
volley this kind of Nick Nolte Eddie
Murphy volley which I liked I look
forward to seeing that evolve once we
get closer in the movie to who Ryan and
I are personally I think it's just
better for everybody including us oh
yeah
pump the hate breaks Thanos how would
you describe yeah oh you're talking
about the character not the actor
playing him ah gosh where do I start
uh well he's the biological son of
Cyclops in Madeline Pryor
Jean Grey is clone and half brother to
Rachel summers and Nate gray I don't
know why those air quotes were in there
okay let's just go with it Domino I'm
lucky luck isn't a superpower it's
certainly not very
is luck absolutely
when I first read about that I never
really questioned it I always thought it
was such a cool power I think it's so
useful it just makes you better at
everything
you don't die everything it just works
out as a director did you attempt
anything in this movie that you've never
attempted before I mean there are some
certain things we did technical sort of
achievements and experiments in terms of
like camera and things that will go
unnoticed but for me I'm really proud of
all right has the success of the first
film change physically well I I had five
bones from my body just removed so I
could just be a little bit more fluid
and both call our bones seven inches of
spine and for no reason at all my coccyx
just cuz I want to see what it looked
like it's so gross it's not making any
contact with me your time's up dumb ass
well that's just lazy writing
[Music]